dans pourquoi on dit je vous raconte ce
qui se cache derrière les expressions de
la langue française alors abonnez vous
et n'oubliez pas que fuite cloche salue
les épées curieuse et les épis curieux
savez vous pourquoi on dit être septième
ciel quand on est profondément heureux
pour savoir pourquoi le bonheur se
logent à cette altitude
il faut remonter à l'antiquité à
l'époque les astronomes ont identifié
sept corps céleste au voisinage de la
terre est à l'image de notre planète
jacques astres est supposé être entouré
d'une sphère transparente son ciel à lui
le premier ciel est celui de la lune
puis viennent ceux de mercure vénus le
soleil mars jupiter et enfin saturn
à l'époque les amoureux montait au
troisième ciel celui de vénus la déesse
de l'amour mais pourquoi s'arrêter en si
bon chemin
avec le temps le nombre de ciel à
franchir pour atteindre le bonheur à
augmenter et ce dernier s'est établi
dans le viième celui de saturne rien
d'étonnant finalement car le chiffre 7
est aussi hautement symbolique dans
beaucoup de religieux eux auraient ainsi
achever son oeuvre
au septième jour les pèlerins à la
mecque doivent faire cette fois le tour
de la kaaba et le chancelier hébreu
possède cette branche
chez les québécois en revanche le
bonheur est beaucoup plus accessible
lorsqu'ils sont heureux nos cousins
d'outre-atlantique ne vont pas au
septième ciel mais disent qu'ils sont
trois au ça fait aussi rêver
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus merci les
épis curieux pour les plus gourmands en
voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]